[SQUEAKING][RUSTLING][CLICKING]
ROBERT TOWNSEND: OK.
So let me update where we
are in terms of the calendar.
I guess a notable
thing is that we
have reached lecture 10
today, Thursday, in terms
of the reading list.
We are-- having done
all the risk-sharing.
Yeah, we're at lecture 10.
So there's a couple of
things that are starred here,
and they obviously both come
up in the lecture today.
One is the early
version of this paper
with Alvarez and
Pawasutipaisit sit
cash, which has a star on it.
It's a little bit rough because
it's kind of, even then,
in the process of revision.
And I have added new material
in the slides that haven't even
made their way into
the working paper yet.
And then there's
Samphantharak and Townsend,
which is describing
the tools we're
going to be using a lot today--
how to organize data, and think
about flows and stocks in terms
of financial accounts and so on.
So, again, the two
starred readings.
Other things you might
enjoy, time permitting,
there's something
on Kenya, M-Pesa.
And I have one slide
describing-- actually
two slides describing
that today;
something on lifecycle planning.
But none of those things
have stars on them.
OK.
So that's the reading list.
The last thing, turning to
the study guide or the lecture
from last time, which
was "Risk and Return
in Village Thailand."
So explain intuitively in words
why multiple technologies can
be chosen to be
operated simultaneously,
and why the rate
of return on some
might be higher than
the rate of return
for the others that
are also operating.
And for that matter, why some
projects are not chosen at all.
If you can, try to use the
language of risk premium,
but don't use it as jargon.
Try to imagine you're telling
someone in your household
or a friend kind of what
we're studying in class.
So I've been calling on people.
Let me just ask for
volunteers today.
Of course, I can call on people.
Any volunteers?
Carrie, you want to
take a crack at this?
AUDIENCE: Is it because
some technologies
have a lower rate of return
because they're riskier?
And the probability of
a high rate of return
is lower for them?
ROBERT TOWNSEND: That's true.
At first blush,
the rate of return
is simply all the possible
returns multiplied
by the respective probability.
So that's kind of inherent
in the technology itself.
But if that were the only
thing going on, then why would
they not choose the one with
the highest expected return?
AUDIENCE: Can I
take a crack at it?
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Yep.
AUDIENCE: Well, I think
they've got-- yeah,
I'm a bit behind
in the readings.
But what it looks
like here is that you
have some technologies that
have a higher expected rate
of return but more risk,
and some technologies that
have the low rate of
return and lower risk.
And basically--
and some of them--
so some of them are--
some people-- it's like some
households might be more like--
it's like, you can have like--
and if these aren't perfectly
correlated, then you might
be able to get a better--
sort of a less risky
rate for the same-- less
risk for the same rate of
return by diversification.
And the reason that
you would have lower--
you would have-- you would
have lower rate of return
technologies in the same--
used at the same time as higher
rate of return technologies,
as the lower rate of
return points, have a--
the lower rate of return
points have a lower risk,
and the higher rate
of return points,
you have to basically
pay a risk--
there's risk
premium there, which
is why it's less desirable
or something like that.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Yep.
OK.
That's pretty good.
Thank you.
Yeah.
What you're
describing is correct.
There's like a mean
variability trade-off
here, a downward-sloping
frontier,
if you want to think
about it that way.
As you move across
different projects
they may have higher
and higher means,
but they come with higher
and higher variance.
So there's a trade-off.
And since households
are risk-averse,
they don't like the variance.
So they pay attention to that.
And you said this also.
You could have two technologies
with the same mean return--
one with a higher variance
than the other one,
and they would never do
the higher variability one
because then there's
no trade-off.
Since they get the same
mean but higher risk,
they wouldn't choose that.
There is a
diversification aspect
that we featured quite a
bit in terms of land plots
and how they want to
diversify, or in village India
over crops and income
sources and so on.
And that's kind of
captured here in a new way,
but it is in here.
Namely, a guess of
what technologies
to operate overall, you can
compute the variability.
And then you look on the
margin about whether to add
or subtract one more.
And you look at its variability
relative to this village
average.
So if it's going to
add to diversification,
it's going to have a return
stream which is low when--
well, say high when the
rest of the village is low.
So that's kind of the
way the diversification
aspect is coming out in this
mean variance framework.
But great.
That's very helpful.
All right.
So here's another one.
Explain how it can be
that while the magnitude
of idiosyncratic risk is
higher than the magnitude
of aggregate risk, nevertheless
the idiosyncratic risk premium
is smaller than the
aggregate risk premium.
So, again, I'll take volunteers.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
So is it-- so I think
it's because when
it comes with
idiosyncratic risk,
it's possible for the village
to distribute the returns
amongst each other.
It's like ex-post.
Whereas, for aggregate
risk, it's like
is risk affecting
the whole village.
And so there's not-- and so
redistribution can't really
benefit anyone when it
comes to things that
affect the village as a whole.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Yep.
Perfect.
Yeah, the last part,
which I didn't read out,
explain in words what gifts
and loans have to do with it,
but you kind of did already.
That's the way they pool
away most, if not all,
of the idiosyncratic risk.
Whereas, in the
aggregate, it's common.
It's hitting everyone.
So essentially, you
can't pool it away.
And this next part
is related to that.
Is there full insurance in these
Thai village economies or not?
And to give it away a bit, not.
And, in particular,
what is it in the data
that is inconsistent
with full risk-sharing?
Volunteers?
AUDIENCE: We find
that in the data
household consumption is still--
is positively correlated with
the idiosyncratic shocks.
So that shows that it's
not full risk-sharing.
But there's still
some risk-sharing
because the coefficient
is really, really small
compared to other coefficients.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Right.
Compared to the coefficients
on gifts and lending,
which absorbs the
bulk of the risk.
So that's a perfect answer.
I am so happy with this class.
I enjoy teaching
you tremendously.
It's very gratifying.
OK.
Thank you.
There's one more-- see
if we can get it in.
Describe one example from
Thai villages of propagation
through networks that
would be inconsistent
with full risk-sharing
and investment efficiency.
And I'm abbreviating.
So this happened at the end of
the lecture, just as a hint.
Can someone described what we
did at the end of the lecture?
Well, it's kind of given away
here in this bullet point,
but I'll read it out anyway.
How can an individual
specific illness shock
turn into an aggregate
village-level downturn?
Volunteers?
AUDIENCE: I think at
the end of the class,
we were talking about how
some of the networks--
how different kinds of networks
are different from each other.
I'm not sure which specific
networks were being compared,
but yeah.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: That's true.
So what happens,
do you recall, when
a household gets hit with
an illness shock that
increases its expenditure?
AUDIENCE: Right.
ROBERT TOWNSEND:
Did nothing happen?
Something?
You remember, or
anyone else remember?
AUDIENCE: I remember
that the households who
are directly connected to
the household who got illness
shocks would [INAUDIBLE] down
their working opportunity
much more than households
who are unconnected
to those illness households.
So through the network,
households who are connected,
who are related to each
other much more maybe shock--
there was an actual
shock between them.
So sudden illness shocks
to these households
may transfer to the
aggregate village
through the [INAUDIBLE].
ROBERT TOWNSEND: OK.
That's a pretty good.
And it's a bit
tricky, this question.
Because there are different
networks in the village.
There's kind of the
risk-sharing insurance network.
There's the labor network.
There's the supply chain
production network.
And they don't coincide.
So if you got hit
with an illness shock,
but nevertheless, you're in this
risk-sharing insurance network,
then part of the-- or
almost all of the shock
gets covered, in come the gifts,
just like we were describing
with the production shock.
However, when that illness
shock is not covered by gifts,
then the household has to
respond on its own in some way.
And it does this by cutting
the number of laborers
that it hires,
and by shrinking--
saving costs by shrinking
its production operations.
And that is what spills
over to other households
along the production network.
So networks could
be good or bad.
Networks are good
for sharing risk,
but they also can be bad because
they propagate contagion.
So that was--
AUDIENCE: So if there was a
full risk-sharing, then the--
then there were no effect on
the employment for the household
who did not get any shock?
Network-- I mean, network--
that was a factor.
Those houses who did
not get any shock
because they are more related
to the households with illness.
But if there was
full risk-sharing,
those households will
not have any effect?
ROBERT TOWNSEND: That's right.
So the emphasis here is on
a very specific household
idiosyncratic shock.
And this-- I drew an
analogy with COVID-19,
but it's a bit unfair.
Because COVID, as we know,
has a contagion effect
literally in the health sense.
And if one person gets it,
people around that person
get it.
So here, though, it's a
different kind of illness.
But it-- and it could be
just an elderly person
in the household.
But still, there
are big expenses--
double the normal expenses.
So they don't have
the budget to manage,
and they have to start either
getting a gift from someone
or cutting.
So when they start
cutting expenses,
that's when it spills over to
other people that they hire
or people.
So this is very
reminiscent, as I
said in class, of what's
going on in the supply chain
networks in the US, for example,
and many other countries.
Although, that's more of a
different kind of health shock.
OK.
Any questions about-- any other
questions about the lecture?
OK.
So then we come to the
lecture for today--
ledgers and management.
In fact, there's a lot
in the lecture today.
I would say I'm
going to give you
a tool to think about,
namely, financial accounts--
income and balance sheet
accounts, in particular.
And then we'll go to
the Thai monthly data
that we were just talking
about, and use the tool
to think about planning--
about wealth planning.
Then we'll take a step back
and add another account.
I'll motivate that account
by thinking about Bitcoin,
as I promised in lecture one,
and link the ledgers of Bitcoin
to the statement of cash flow.
And hence, back to
the Thai villages.
In particular, I'll talk about
distributed ledgers, which
is a big part of Bitcoin--
Bitcoin, blockchain,
and distributed ledgers.
And then having
introduced that concept,
I'll focus on the use
almost exclusively
of paper currency
in Thailand, the use
of almost exclusively
electronic transfers in Sweden,
and something in
between in Kenya,
which has two different kinds
of monies, essentially--
privately issued e-money
from a cell phone
provider, and a public Fiat
money, Kenyan shillings.
And then I'll end-- and so
these three things for Thailand,
Sweden, and Kenya
are about cash--
various concepts of cash
and cash management.
And then we'll come
back to the ledgers
again and talk about trusted
third parties, some problems
and management
that may or may not
show up at the individual
level, but definitely
show up at the wholesale
level at the level
of financial infrastructure.
OK.
So here's a statement of income.
And forgive me if this is
a review for some of you.
These things aren't hard,
but they're a bit tedious.
So we talk about sources of
income and uses of income.
And the sources of income,
as in the Thai data,
come from cultivation,
livestock, fish and shrimp.
This is a wage-earning
household primarily,
a little bit of livestock.
So the line entry here
is almost entirely
from wage, labor, income.
Those are the sources.
And then the uses, so
to speak, or you could
say revenues versus costs--
you have expenses from each
of the activities-- livestock.
If they're in debt, they
have interest expenses.
There's that depreciation that
we talked about last time.
And then this is
charges against revenue.
So in addition to having
expenses for production,
they might pay taxes--
these guys don't.
But they can either
consume the rest or save.
Advantage of the
financial accounts
is that everything balances.
So in this case,
revenue is totally
balanced by charges
against revenue.
And if you're-- as we
did-- taking the Thai data
and thinking of all the
line items then creating
the accounts, and if these
left- and right-hand sides
don't balance, we know
we something wrong.
And we have to go back and
iterate and figure out--
excluded a variable, or put
it in the inappropriate spot.
So it's a great
discipline device.
The balance sheet is stocks
of stuff at a point in time,
namely, liabilities and assets.
So the obvious
liability would be
debt, which this household has.
This is really
somebody's numbers.
This is a real person,
I want to remind you.
More on that momentarily.
And the debt's
about 37,000 baht.
And the assets that
the household has
could be real or financial.
The financial assets are a big
chunk of it in paper currency
and some deposits at the bank.
And real assets, in this
case, household fixed assets.
So we went through
some examples last time
when we talked about rates
of return, because we
had in the numerator
profits, which
is on the previous account
revenue minus expenses.
And here, profits over capital.
And here we have the real
and also financial capital.
Now, again, these
things balance.
But here, there's a big
item that I deliberately
didn't mention at first to
get your attention, which
is if you take assets
minus liabilities,
hopefully net worth is positive.
If liabilities were
greater than assets,
this guy's bankrupt, at least
in the accounting sense.
So for almost all
these households,
assets are greater
than liabilities.
And the difference is something
we call equity or net worth.
And that enters oddly
on the right-hand side
with liabilities, precisely
so that the two sides
of the financial account, or
the balance sheet account,
are equal to each other.
OK.
So now with those concepts, the
statement and balance sheet,
would take it to an application.
So this is a wealth
planner, which
we implemented to that household
and all of the other ones.
What is the household
we imagine to be doing?
Namely, maximize discounted
expected utility.
So you've kind of seen
versions of this before.
You saw it first with
respect to storage of seed
and so on in the
medieval village economy.
We've got a finite
horizon here that happens,
but more on that momentarily.
So it's discounted utility.
This is constant relative risk
aversion, with a risk averse
coefficient of kappa.
Delta is the discount rate.
And the end of life,
which is T, they
may bequest assets
to their kids.
It looks like a
similar function,
but there's an extra
term here, which
is beta, almost for bequest.
And again, the notation changes
from one lecture to the next.
But anyway, so that's
another parameter.
We have delta, kappa, and beta.
We're going to have to figure
out what they are because they
will impact the solution.
Subject to the big
constraint-- now,
again, you've seen a version
of this in the medieval village
economy because we had
resources available today, which
they could eat or store in
two different ways, which
would determine resources
available next period.
Here, they have
wealth today, and they
have resources
available today, which
is the beginning of period
stocks, their wealth,
plus income--
more on that momentarily.
And they can either eat
it-- and the difference
between what they have and
what they eat, they invest.
So some fraction, Z,
goes into risky assets,
and the residual 1 minus Z
fraction goes into safe assets.
So this is a lifecycle
portfolio allocation problem.
A little bit more detail
about these numbers--
so the income term is the
second and third term.
If gamma is equal to 1, then the
mu, which is the mean income,
cancels out.
And this household is
entirely on its own
with income fluctuations
around the mean.
When gamma is equal to 0,
this whole term is gone,
and the household
has its mean income.
So gamma here, between 0 and 1,
is capturing the risk-sharing
that we know is prevalent
in the Thai villages.
So that's the way all that
risk-sharing stuff entered
into the individual program.
It looks like self
insurance, but it isn't.
Because the income stream can
be attenuated due to the gifts.
But it can also vary
over households.
We have to elicit
from the households
how big or small gamma is.
This is a premium if the--
sorry-- an indemnity if
the household head dies,
all these village villagers
get together and contribute
something to help the bereaved
household with expenses
and so on. c is consumption.
Big C is committed consumption.
So these are things the
household tells us they're
going to do no matter what.
And so we enter as a
particular expense.
All right.
So here is a bit of what
we show the household.
We explain to them--
we go and interview them.
And that we have been getting
data from them all along,
but this is extra.
So we tell them we want
to know how much they're
planning to give to
their kids, if anything.
Try to elicit their
current income profile
and future movements and income.
Get their goals, and get
their current wealth.
And then we're
going to tell them
how much they should be
saving, and how to save it
in risky versus safe things.
And particular, whether they
might want to be borrowing.
I don't know.
Some people don't like these
little cartoon characters.
It's an attempt to
communicate clearly.
So we don't say,
tell us everything.
We say, let us demonstrate
to you how this works.
We'll show you the results
of another villager.
We asked that household
whether or not
they want to leave
money to their kids.
And this household said, no.
My kids are going to be
much richer than I am.
They're going to
work in Bangkok.
I don't think I need to
leave anything to my children
after my death.
So this household
said zero baht.
I made the mistake
once of having
this interview with the
mother and the daughter
present in the room
at the same time.
Obviously, that was awkward.
[LAUGHS] OK.
Collect inputs-- so we need to
calibrate this income process.
And we give, for example, Chen.
Now you're going
to see some Thai.
Sorry.
Anyway, wage earners earn a
regular income of 10,000 baht.
Expects to work to age
65, and then income
drops to something very
small, which is a pension.
So that's this picture.
10,000 baht, age
65, the household's
currently young, actually.
Drops to zero.
Or this guy--
different example--
has a little shop
as a business--
very volatile income.
Expects to keep its business
running until age 60--
currently age 25.
And then receive some small
income, again, from the kids.
Oh, yeah.
Kids give money to
the parents, you guys.
You hear that?
[LAUGHS]
OK.
Depends on where you're from
whether you can relate to this.
Another example-- this household
has regular increasing income
for 30 years.
But, again, income
starts to drop.
However, they're going to
go into a second occupation,
and income only slowly.
So I stay-- we used to stay in
the village with the headman.
But eventually,
Thailand has motels.
And you'll often see an elderly
couple running the motel.
That's now their new
business, relative to what
they used to do, et cetera.
So these are just
three examples.
So what about goals?
So do you expect to send
your kids to college?
Is that a planned expense?
Or in the future open a
business or buy a new TV?
But what we want
are expenses they're
going to be no matter what.
So yes or no, depending.
In this particular
example household,
we give them car purchase.
Was that obligatory?
No.
Send the kids to college?
Yes.
How many years away?
15 years-- kids are young.
And it's going to cost
$10,000 for three years--
30,000 baht.
That's about-- it's a lot
less than US expenses.
It's not an MIT tuition.
All right.
So now we have wealth, so w.
This is tricky.
Money available to save
or spend or invest.
So if you have a car
that's worth 10,000 baht.
You think-- it's used, but
you could sell it easily.
Then we would count that as
a household asset or business
asset-- could be sold.
If they own land
worth 100,000 baht,
they may never plan to
sell it, and may not even
be productive land.
So we don't count it
unless they said it was.
If it's productive, we want
to avoid double counting.
So here's the thing.
You would count
the asset, or you
would count the return stream.
You cannot count both.
The value of land should be the
discounted capitalized value
of net profits from farming.
That's how much
the land is worth.
You don't want to count
both the land as an asset,
and also ask the households
about the income stream.
So generally, we
don't count assets
that we are using in calculating
the income stream unless they
say, I'm going to stop
farming at a certain date.
And how much would the
land be worth then?
If we count income up to that
point, then we count the land.
So let's run the planner.
I'll give you examples.
We created an Excel
spreadsheet with the answers
to all the
household's questions,
and then enter it into
the computer and run it.
I'm not showing you all of them.
The second household--
we told this household
to cut its expenses on
consumption quite a bit.
They weren't saving enough,
and to put almost all of it
in safe assets.
More interesting is
the life cycle picture.
So here's what the
planner recommends
that the household should do.
Namely, let's start down here.
We've got income in red.
That's the elicited
profile over time
that I just told you about.
The consumption is endogenous
variable, obviously.
It's in black.
So here, we told the household
to cut its consumption
expenditure a lot and much
lower than its current income
in order to build up the assets.
So here's the total
level of assets.
And then when income drops
to little or nothing,
they eat off the assets.
So this is just
saving for retirement.
Most of it's in safe assets,
not so much in risky,
and there's no borrowing.
Another household basically
had committed consumption
that is going to get
it in big trouble,
even though they said they were
going to do it no matter what.
When we ran the
planner at the time
that they have
this high expense--
I think it was for starting a
business-- they really didn't
have the resources to cover it.
Now, they try to
increase their savings
with income over consumption.
But in this median simulation
scenario, it's just not enough.
So when that big expense
comes, on average, they
use up all of their assets.
Consumption isn't
dropping to zero.
You remember, it's constant
relative risk aversion.
So marginal utility
of consumption at zero
is infinite.
Although, you can't see
this, but we gave them
some subsistence bundle.
So they don't
really go bankrupt.
They survive.
Well, they don't die
when they go bankrupt.
They continue to survive because
of that subsistence bundle.
What else is going on here?
They kind of know in advance--
the planner knows-- state
by state, year by year
that they're in trouble.
So actually, they
start borrowing.
Of course, given our
subsistence consumption rule,
if the median scenario
occurs, they're
not going to pay back the loan.
They get to default on the
loan, and they know that.
Call this gambling
for redemption.
They're starting to
do risky things too,
and borrowing, leveraging
up, with the idea
that there's a good chance
they're not going to make it.
Here, the planner
is not the bank.
Whether the bank would make
this loan is another issue.
Anyway, they
survive this episode
and continue to live another day
with their fluctuating income.
So the rest of this looks
like the other diagram
to some extent.
OK.
So we show the households
these pictures,
and try to explain to
them what's going on.
And there are all kinds
of households in the data.
And some of them, in fact,
are very conservative,
and they have fluctuations
in income and consumption.
Consumption is never more than
the lowest possible income
draw, and mostly, a lot
lower than their income draw.
So they're saving like
crazy, and their net worth
is growing at 20% per year.
Sounds good to me, by the way.
But they're probably
over-saving.
But we're very conservative
about what we tell them.
We don't tell them
that that's bad.
That's fine if they
want to do that.
It's the ones who
are eating too much
and not saving that
we're more worried about.
OK.
So this looks like
Thai villages,
but the life cycle
model is universal.
And just to shift gears, this
is Larry Kotlikoff's website.
He's both a professor
and an entrepreneur.
So he is selling this
product, this ESB planner.
But he has a lot of great
economic research on life cycle
planning.
And no one wants to
splurge today and starve
tomorrow, nor the opposite.
Lifecycle consumption-smoothing
balances our goals.
Now, you would think,
could everyone do that?
The answer is no.
There's only two companies I
know of in the US that do this.
And it's not Vanguard.
It's not Fidelity.
They're adopting kind
of a rule of thumb.
They ask you what's
your current expenses?
And then say 70% of that
is target for retirement.
And then how much do you have
to save to make that goal?
And so consumption could be low
because you're saving a lot.
And that can end up in a
very imbalanced profile
in which you're starving today
in order to splurge tomorrow.
Whereas, we're using this
strictly concave utility,
and so is Larry, to say we
want to smooth over time.
Just like we want to
smooth over bad shocks,
we want to smooth over time,
as in the medieval village seed
and so on.
OK.
So let me make a transition
then to the other account, which
is cash flow.
And I'm going to do this
by explaining a little bit
about Bitcoin, and many of
you probably know about this
already.
So every transection in Bitcoin
is an encoded message sent out
with a-- generated with a
private/public key scheme,
which has the advantage
that it's known
which node sent the message.
And there's full
commitment to the message.
You can't go back and
deny that you sent it.
And it prevents fraud.
Nobody can transact on
your ID because nobody else
has the private key,
unless you get careless.
So a transection in
Bitcoin is the moving
of the coin from one
person to another.
The message sent
might be, I want
to give the coin to
person X. Arguably,
because person X is a merchant
and you're buying something
or whatever.
The various transactions are
accumulated into a block,
and the block is subject to a
validation routine, which is
mining and it's quite costly.
I'll come back to that later.
The point here is
that Bitcoin is
combining two different things.
One is the statement
of cash flow
as the coin moves from out or
in to the person in question.
And the other is
the balance sheet,
which is at a moment in time
how many coins do you own?
So the accounting of the
cash flow works for Bitcoin.
It also works for paper
currency in Thailand.
So let me show you a
statement of cash flow
as an accounting statement.
Remember, before, I showed
you income and balance sheet.
I haven't shown you the cash
flow statement until now.
It's pretty small print.
Let me just give you
the big picture here.
We have cash flow
from production,
which you can
imagine, if you sold
something in got paper
currency as a consequence,
you'd have a plus.
If you're buying fertilizer
to grow the rice,
you have a minus sign.
So you have inflows and outflows
associated with production.
You can spend money
on consumption.
That's typically an outflow.
You can spend money
on investment, also
typically an outflow.
So we have cash flow from
consumption and investment,
and then we have cash
flow from financing,
which is, you can put cash
in the bank as a deposit,
or you could borrow cash.
Hopefully, you get
it as an inflow,
through gifts and so on.
So cash flow from production,
consumption, and financing
are the three categories.
And this stuff up
here is complicated.
When I said I'd shown you
the income statement, but not
the cash flow statement, you
may have been thinking, well,
aren't they the same?
And the answer is, well, they
could be, but not necessarily.
So if you're a business, and
you sell something and the guy
doesn't pay you, then
he's going to pay later,
that's an account receivable,
but there's no cash.
So the sale would
count as revenue
in the income statement
using the accrued
notion of accounting,
but it would not
count as a cash inflow.
So oddly enough,
this top stuff here
is just starting with
the income statement
and making adjustments
to it according
to whether the
movement of cash you
have to adjust one
way or the other.
So, I mean, if you have
an account receivable,
and you didn't get
the cash, then you
have to subtract off
from accrued income
to get the cash
flow because you're
counting something that
is not yet associated
with the cash inflow.
All right.
Mainly, I'm just trying to
give you the big picture here.
This is the statement
of cash flow.
And it is true, and this is
automatically true in Bitcoin,
that you can check whether the
change in cash holdings that
come at the bottom line of
the statement of cash flow
are exactly equal or not
to the change in cash
that we have on
the balance sheet.
So you have cash in
a moment in time,
and then you have these
inflows and outflows.
You have cash in
a future period.
In each of those periods
now and in the future,
you have two balance sheets.
Take the difference in
the balance sheet, that's
the change in the cash
flow on the balance sheet,
and it should be
exactly equal to what's
showing up here in the cash
flow from the statement of cash
flow.
So we run a check
on the Thai data.
And, again, if we're making a
mistake these are not equal,
and that's a big guide to us.
I should save this
for later, but I
will tell you that no
top US survey does this.
Not the Survey of Consumer
Finances, not the PSID.
They did not gather
variables and check
what they gathered against
these comprehensive statements
of integrated accounts.
And Bitcoin is automatic.
Because you either have it in
your account and you spend it,
or you don't spend it and
it's still in the account.
So that's kind of the
unspoken advantage of Bitcoin.
There is something that people
talk about a lot on Bitcoin
and that is consensus.
So I keep giving this
example in Bitcoin
that Bob wants to
transfer a coin to Alice.
We have both Alice's
accounts and Bob's account.
And what Bob gives up
is what Alice gets.
So the accounts have to be
consistent with each other
across the households.
And that is true in Bitcoin.
But it is not--
well, and again, this
is a bit technical for
now, but the whole thing
about the mining and the
validation of the transactions
in Bitcoin is to precisely
be assured that Bob is not
double-spending the coin.
You can't spend it twice.
And they kind of
figured out a way
to do that-- a very
ingenious way to do that.
But anyway, the concept of
reconciliation and validation
could be taken to accounting
in the Thai villages,
in the sense that we
really did try to measure
all the transactions.
And when a household says that
it bought something with cash,
if the person they bought
it from is in the village,
then that person
should get the cash,
while the person in
question is giving it up.
So it should appear twice, both
in the accounts of the person
buying and the accounts
of the person selling.
So with one of your
former classmates,
who was a student in this class
about two years ago, Chad,
we set out--
he wanted to help
on these projects.
He was an RA.
And I'm not pushing that
hard, but if any of you
are interested, let me know.
There's a lot of
interesting stuff to do.
So Chad was very interested,
so here's what he did.
He looked literally to
see whether what shows up
in one person's account
is also showing up
in the other one or not.
And these are some
of the details
of going through and doing
that as an algorithm.
He created these accounts.
He checks to see
if it's reported.
If not, et cetera, et cetera.
Now, right in the
middle of this slide
it jumps from
Thailand and the thing
that Chad was doing to a very
different application, which is
the stock market in Australia.
So the stock market
in Australia is
about to run on distributed
ledgers the way Bitcoin does.
Not using Bitcoin,
but using the ledgers.
And so the idea is when
someone owns the stock,
and there's a
buyer and a seller,
the traditional legacy system
is that they enter into a deal.
And then only after a
day, or maybe three,
the process of reconciliation
kicks in and then they settle.
So the trade of the stocks is
separate from the settlement
of the stocks.
And believe it or not, there's
often huge discrepancies.
For one thing,
prices have moved.
So a household could
claim, I didn't buy it.
And in the New York
financial markets,
there was an attempt to provide
this in the repo market.
Because every day in
the US repo market
with treasuries and so
on, they spend two hours
at the end of each day
after the end of trading
trying to reconcile accounts.
State Street Bank here in Boston
is a big third-party broker
for people that hold
accounts, and it does
this kind of reconciliation.
It's quite costly and
quite time-consuming.
But if you're entering these
trades onto the ledgers,
there's instantaneous
reconciliation.
And so they could settle
right away if they wanted to.
The decision to not pay for
it is a credit decision.
They're not forced to
settle immediately.
But in principle,
trade and settlement
can happen at exactly
the same time all
through the distributed ledgers.
And the one in Australia
is able to process
115 million daily trades.
It's 6,300 trades per second
continuously over five hours.
That well exceeds the
volume in Bitcoin.
Bitcoin is not capable of doing
this because of the mining.
But these other
ledger technologies
are a lot faster
and a lot cheaper.
So let's come back
to the village
and think about how an
individual household is
managing its currency.
Let me back up for a second.
That seemed like an
abrupt transition.
I featured in lecture one that
we will say a lot about Bitcoin
and cryptocurrencies,
and it's spread out
throughout the lectures.
So Bitcoin, blockchain,
and distributed ledgers--
it's the first time
it really came up.
And I started with a ledger.
So when we're talking
about financial accounts,
that's why I started
to bring in Bitcoin.
And we will revisit
Bitcoin in other lectures
when we talk about monetary
economics and so on.
OK.
So now, back to paper
currency management.
I say paper currency just
to constantly remind myself
that cash is kind of ambiguous.
When you talk about cash in the
US you mean, currency, yeah.
But also, demand deposits
and other variables,
like maybe even debit cards.
But in Thailand,
it's paper currency.
They love it.
That's what they use.
We're on that momentarily.
So I'm going to, in notation,
describe a Miller/Orr model--
the management of
cash for firms,
for business firms,
which do not have
regular nor predictable flows.
And the result solving the
model is rather intuitive.
There's going to be bounds.
So cash holdings
can drift around.
But when they go
above an upper bound,
it's time to make an adjustment
and deposit the paper
in the bank, or lend it out.
And likewise, when it
goes below a lower bound,
they're going to
have to withdraw
money or call in a loan.
So sometimes that lower
bound is zero, obviously.
You can't run out of
stock of something.
It can't go negative.
So that's going to be what
the solution looks like.
So let me introduce a little
bit of notation, e being
expenditure outflows of paper
currency, which looks like c.
But it's basically
more than consumption.
It's all expenses out, and
then y being stuff coming in.
OK.
So expenditure is outflows
minus inflows, which
could be positive or negative.
So we postulate a
stochastic process
for the cash flows,
expenditure flows, and estimate
in the Thai data.
We postulate that
mostly things are
pretty smooth and predictable.
Delta refers to the length
of the time interval.
And it's easier conceptually to
think of delta as equal to 1.
So with roughly
probability 1/2, they're
going to have an
expenditure of c,
but it could be a higher
order of magnitude, sigma.
Or with residual
probability roughly 1/2,
it's c minus sigma.
So these are the ups and
downs of expenditures--
probabilistic basis.
How big or small depends
on how big sigma is.
And I keep saying
roughly probability 1/2,
because there are these
zapper things that are very
large inflows and outflows.
So expenditure is an outflow.
So positive zapper, Zp, is a
very large expenditure that
happens with probability kappa.
Again, say delta equal 1.
So this could be like
2% or 3% of the time,
there is an outflow
which is more
than two standard
deviations away
from the mean positive outflow.
Or it could be an inflow.
So these are rare
revenues coming
in with different kappas
and different Zs, which
will be estimated in the data.
And these shocks-- you
take the probability
of the positive
outflow, the probability
of the negative outflow add
them together, delta, say,
is still equal to 1.
So with probability
1, something happens.
With probability 1 minus
the sum of those kappas,
you're in this middle branch.
And that's the 1/2
adjusted up or down.
As always, I'm assuming
you will interrupt me
if things are not clear.
OK.
So let's think about
how much cash they
have in house that's paper.
So they have a certain amount
of cash in a moment in time.
They have an expenditure
outflow, which
could be positive or negative.
And they're at t,
and we're going
to try to do the accounting
for how much money they would
have at t plus delta,
where again, delta
could be equal to 1.
Money at t less outflows,
and then they could adjust.
They could either withdraw
money or deposit it.
So these two things the
w and d is endogenous.
And the model is going to
have to solve for w and d,
when to do it, as I was
saying, and how much to do.
And that will result in
this endogenously determined
statement of cash flow.
You can think about this
like life cycle planning,
except now it's
not over 50 years.
It may be a matter of a
couple of weeks or 30 days.
In the data, it's 30
days because that's
when we get the data.
They're trying to
minimize costs.
Now, there's two costs.
One is kind of obvious,
really, for economists,
which is if you're holding cash
and it doesn't earn interest,
you've lost the interest
you could have earned if you
had deposited it in the bank.
So that's a real cost
to the household.
That's the opportunity
cost to the household.
We're going to let the
interest rate in the bank
be capital R. If you
hold too much cash,
you're giving up a lot
of foregone interest.
That's a cost.
There's also a physical
adjustment cost
to get to the bank, which you
can think of as the hassle,
or in these villages you've
got to get in your truck
and drive to the village,
to the town, et cetera.
So that should have
had the notation here,
but it's a little b.
You'll see a little
b momentarily.
So the next slide-- don't panic.
I'm going to walk you
through the value function.
It looks pretty
intense at first.
They're sitting here with a
certain amount of money, m,
and then deciding
whether they want
to stay put and carry m into
the second period or adjust.
Now, if m is already
negative, they're in trouble.
Can't go negative, so
they have to adjust.
And you get this cost,
b, which is gone.
This cost function
is not utility.
It's not net profits.
It's a cost, and they're
trying to minimize the cost.
So this is enters positively
because it's a cost.
They've gone to all the
costs, to getting to the bank,
they get to make an
adjustment, which
means they can choose a
new m prime going out.
And so they'll try to minimize
the value from that point
on by that choice of m prime--
minimize the cost
from that point on.
Here, m is positive,
but they still
get to choose whether
to adjust or not.
And if they don't
adjust, they keep it.
They suffer the
opportunity cost,
the lost interest in the bank.
And then they'll have their
value function tomorrow,
which is discounted by little r.
That's like a discount rate.
And things next
period are stochastic.
So you take expectations
over the future e values
following that
stochastic process.
So this is v of m minus
e is all expectation,
is all written down here in
terms of these branches, which
is positive zappers, negative
zappers, ups and downs, roughly
probability 1/2, et cetera.
So this is the expected
cost in the future
if you don't make a
monetary adjustment today.
So this is the
second or third time
you've seen these
value functions.
I introduced them at the
end of the medieval village
dynamic programming problem.
We then used that last class
to talk about implications
of risk sharing for production,
with the planner's value
function.
This is the third time.
This is the value function for a
household minimizing its costs.
More fun-- let me show
you some pictures.
So these are real live people.
This is the cash flow
of this house-- the cash
holdings of this household.
Up and up and up
and up she goes.
This one also had a
trend, and then boom,
down, and then to zero,
and then back up again.
You can't see it very well.
I'm sorry.
The pictures are too small.
But what's plotted over here are
net cash inflows or outflows,
along with, say, a deposit
when you have a net inflow,
or a withdrawal when
you have a net outflow.
So there's three lines
here, and sometimes
things correspond the
way I was just implying.
You're short, so you
withdraw, et cetera.
But when-- you
can't see much here,
but when you integrate
it out and look
at the consequence
for the levels
using this flow equation,
then you can see what
their stocks are.
It looks like a lot of money.
It is going to be unbelievable--
unbelievable in
the sense of three
years research running to try
to understand this pattern.
So how much money does
a typical household
have-- currency, paper,
squirreled away in the house?
In the rural villages
that we were looking at,
roughly 32 months
worth of consumption.
What's in your wallet?
You're going to say credit card.
These guys-- it's
not in a wallet.
It's in the house or
hidden in the backyard.
Almost three years worth
of expenditures in cash--
cash equivalent consumption.
We measure the consumption
for each household,
and we see how much
cash they have,
which we measured in the data.
32 months-- it's unbelievable.
And we also get
deposits and withdrawals
measured in the data.
That's a lot of
detail to absorb.
Let me show you what's
going on in the model.
We estimate the cash flow.
We recover all the
parameters that we need,
take a stand on the
interest rate in the bank,
and then look at how small
or big the cost would be.
b is varying down here.
And the consequences for
currency, especially but also
withdrawals and deposits.
So taking the reality to be
the calibrated expenditure
flows we see in the data, along
with the few other reasonable
assumptions, I assure
you we can look
at how much cash they
should be holding relative
to consumption.
That's this blue line.
And we can barely
get it up to three.
The number in the data is 32.
I mean, you could imagine
increasing those costs
and decreasing the interest.
And this is like asymptoting
out to something flat.
So you end up with
something ridiculous.
The model isn't working.
You don't go to the bank
and forego two years
worth of consumption
while you're
doing your banking transection.
It's just not a
reasonable value.
The sign makes sense.
The higher the cost,
b, of going to the bank
to either withdraw or deposit,
the less you're going to do it.
So when you do it, the
transactions are bigger.
And meanwhile, you're
holding more cash.
If b goes to infinity,
then it's all in cash.
Forget the bank.
And when you go
rarely, then you have
to make up a big difference.
And this is the
frequency, which again,
as b goes up, the frequency
of going to the bank
is going down.
Question-- so because we
did that life cycle planner,
we wanted to evaluate as a
randomized controlled trial
how well or poorly it was
working, and in the process,
we gathered monthly data
for the urban household.
So we're not in
villages anymore.
We're in towns or even
city neighborhoods.
In each of the four
provinces, we basically
replicated all the
existing surveys.
So the same questions
are being asked.
And this is kind of
buried here, but if you
look at the normalized cash
in terms of consumption
for the urban sample,
and look over here,
we got a number of 3.87--
much closer to 3.
Nothing like the 37.
Well, actually, I should
be over here at the median.
So it's 1.94.
But when we do some
adjustments in the data,
I'm happy to tell
you about them.
That's within
reach of the model.
We calibrate the model again
using the cash statistics--
the zapping, big
shock, small shock,
how often they happen,
et cetera et cetera,
and get a model prediction.
And the implied
value, m, depending
on whether you use the
mean or the median,
is something like 2,
which is close to what
we're getting in the data.
So now we're in
kind of business,
in the sense that a reasonable
economic model is actually
predicting pretty well how
much cash they're holding.
Whereas, in the rural
data it was a disaster.
We didn't get close.
So now we switch into how
can we understand the error
that the households are making
with their cash management?
And the guess is--
several guesses.
Some turned out to be
correct and some not.
So why would cash
holdings be so much lower
in the urban area relative
to the rural area?
Is it because households
in the urban survey deposit
more often in larger amounts?
Or is it because they withdraw
in the urban areas less
and withdraw smaller amounts?
So for deposits, it turns out
households in the rural area
deposit more and not less, and
they deposit larger amounts.
So this is exactly
the opposite of what
we would have predicted because
the cash is going into the bank
or into the local money market.
However, for
withdrawals, it works
the way we would
have conjectured,
that when urban households
put money in the bank
they don't withdraw
it very often,
and they withdraw a lot less.
It almost looks like
they're putting their proxy
for their salary into the bank.
And any other money which they
have, from business and so on,
goes into the bank
and stays there.
They just withdraw what
they need for consumption,
taking a, quote unquote,
salary equivalent out
and leaving the rest in.
So this is why their
money value's a lot lower.
There's still something to fix,
which just like in life cycle
planner, we could create from
the research cash flow app
and put it on the phone and tell
households how to manage it.
And, in fact, the
question is, why are they
having cash at all?
Why don't they just put
it on their cell phone?
And that brings us to--
oh.
And the costs of
mismanagement of currency
are very high--
something like 9 and 1/2%
of monthly consumption.
That's huge in economics.
Say, exaggerate a bit--
10, or call it 5 if you want.
5% of monthly consumption
could be saved or used
for consumption if they just
managed their currency better.
So one way to put this--
enormous cost of
mismanagement of petty cash.
Businesses get cash
advisory services.
They pay for it.
Why should these poor
households not have access
to better management tools?
OK.
Sorry.
That's my view.
OK.
Go to Sweden.
How much paper currency
are they using?
Close to nothing.
They're gone-- it's gone.
This is the amount of currency
relative to GDP ever-declining.
This is the absolute
level of cash,
going down in an absolute
not only relative basis.
So I got this and this
slide from the governor
of the Riksbank in Sweden.
So I don't know whether you
will appreciate the humor here.
But this is a
picture of a stone.
So economists and others
have written books
about the first coins,
the first use of cash,
and there were claims on
stones that were buried
at the bottom of the lake.
So now in Sweden, they're
transferring the stone around
on their cell phone.
Well, not really.
It's Swish, basically.
They have a bank account,
and for no money at all
households can transfer cash
to each other, buy things,
and so on.
And it's replaced
the paper currency.
It's actually a bit of a
concern for them, which
is why they're thinking
if there's no paper
currency other than
reserves, there's
no role for the central bank.
So they feel they should
be providing a payment
service as a backup.
So they're going to create,
almost surely, a central bank
digital currency.
So households will
have digital accounts
in the central bank, which is
what South Africa is doing.
China has a different
version of it and so on.
This happened in the Bahamas.
They created something
called the Sand Dollar.
The virus is
accelerating this problem
because people need
government aid,
and they can't get the aid--
truck the paper
currency over there.
When this disastrous Hurricane
Dorian destroyed an island
in the Bahamas, they couldn't
get emergency assistance.
So these are things that are
happening all over the world
right now.
This last slide is Kenya.
And I mentioned they have
two kinds of currency.
One is Kenyan shillings--
used to be a British colony.
And the other is
e-credits at Safaricom,
which is a cell phone provider.
So what you do is you
take your shillings,
you go to this Safaricom agent.
You give him your
Fiat money, and you
get credited cell
accounts called M-Pesa.
And then you can use
that to give to your mom
back in the village, who
goes to the agent there
and transfers it back
out into shillings,
or you can buy stuff.
So here you see the use
of the paper currency,
but also this e-currency,
which is created by Safaricom.
And it has reached
almost everybody.
Some economies try to do this.
We kind of tried in Thailand.
I have not yet succeeded.
In Kenya, even the
lowest income quartile--
we need to update this graph.
Tavneet Suri did this.
Roughly, 85% of the
low-income population,
and a similar, higher number
for those with no bank accounts,
are using Safaricom.
With no bank accounts--
in other words,
you don't need the traditional
legacy infrastructure.
And this is, again, the allure,
the so-called disintermediation
that the fintechs are
bringing to the world.
Of course, the commercial
bankers don't like it much.
We talked about risk-sharing.
And Tavneet and her
co-author, Billy Jack,
looked at how much consumption
is being smooth in Kenya,
comparing households
who have not yet
gotten early on the M-Pesa
expansion versus those
that did.
And there's a lot more
smoother consumption,
which you see these
common themes.
We did risk-sharing.
We did gift giving
in Thai villages.
Now people are giving gifts
and transfers through M-Pesa.
And so it has an impact.
Well, what's the big deal?
It's a big deal for Kenya.
Sweden already has
this infrastructure.
It's not a big deal.
But it makes a big deal
for low-income countries.
There are some
qualifications, though.
First of all, it's not
on a distributed ledger.
So you have to trust Safaricom
to keep the accounts properly,
and they have the cash.
So they're supposed to put
it in a commercial bank.
You trust them to do that.
So you have to rely on a
third-party vendor in Kenya.
Not only that, the
money's in the bank,
and Kenya is subject to runs.
So how safe is that?
You may think you're going
to get the money back,
but will you really?
And in other economies, they
don't have that kind of trust,
so it doesn't take off.
The other thing is those
agents, these guys,
they run out of stuff.
So you go and take
your shillings
and say I want M-Pesa.
And they can't create it.
There's no net creation.
It has to be a
one-to-one transfer.
They have to have it in
their accounts already.
And if don't have
it in the account,
they've got to say, well,
wait, or come back tomorrow.
Likewise, and perhaps
more obviously
for the currency withdrawal,
say here's my cell account.
I want to cash it out.
Oh, I don't have that
cash in my drawer.
What Tavneet discovered is
these agents are kind of linked
to each other in an
informal money market,
giving gifts to each
other, actually,
and borrowing and
lending in order
to smooth the fluctuation,
from smoothing at the household
level, to smoothing at
the wholesale level,
and similar models would apply.
So this brings us to
the theme of building
financial infrastructure.
How can we not just
get currency on ledgers
and transfer it
around in a cheap way?
How can we build in the trust?
And how can we deal
with this shortage
problem among over-the-counter
vendors and agents and so on?
And next lecture,
starting next time,
we're going to do mechanism
design and private information,
and I'll tell you
how to design--
at some point-- how
to design this system.
All right.
Went over by an
extra minute today.
Questions?
All right.
So otherwise, I'll see you
next Thursday or in my office
momentarily.